I'm playing probably a I'm gonna say I'm
playing about 150 in the world level
tennis just now that's probably that's
probably where I'm at in terms of my
game and practice I'm hitting the ball
well sort of some of my decisions like
it on the match core aren't as good and
and my movements not as good as as as
what I would like it to be
I probably shouldn't expect that it's
gonna be perfect just now but I'm hoping
the next or at three or four months with
a little bit more time and you know a
bit more bit more training and also
getting used to playing matches at the
highest level again that will start to
feel a bit better
are you happy to give it more time are
you happy where you're at it's it's a
difficult one because when if you've
been competing at the highest level and
then you're losing in the third round of
a challenger it's easy to be
disappointed with that and want to do
more but also I'm happier now than I was
two years ago when I was making like you
know when I first had the injury I made
the quarterfinals of Wimbledon but I got
zero enjoyment out of that at all so you
know what you care about more is it
making the quarterfinals of Wimbledon
and being in Lords of pain or playing
tennis maybe not to level you'd won but
still being able to get some enjoyment
out of it and just maybe not doing quite
as well have you done any different
things in your quest to get back to full
fitness for me not so much about trying
to get back to full fitness it's just
more that one once I sort of went
through the issues of my hip you sort of
think a little bit bit more like post
playing as well and I you know want to
try and protect my joints as as much as
as possible and yeah started using you
know collagen supplement which hopefully
will sort of help protect my joints and
certainly would prevent you know the
issues like I've had was my right hip I
want to look at the left one now
hopefully that they'll help look after a
bit better do you have a special diet
do you have an extraordinary diet when
you get up in the morning what would you
eat
no I like bagels I also like like this
morning I had had some Cheerios with
banana chopped in two which is what what
my kids had as well but yeah I mean when
I'm competing and when I'm on the road I
eat really well and then when I'm at
home I'm bit more relaxed with her to be
honest so you can't be a bit naughty
yeah I shot some chocolate biscuits as
that's that's an issue familiar